– Aber du kennst ihn doch überhaupt nicht.
Nico hasst seinen Bruder.
– Nico hasst seinen Bruder nicht.
Es ist kompliziert, aber eigentlich ist
Pepe in Ordnung.
– Na klar …
– Und er kennt sich aus.
Das ist die Gelegenheit für meine Idee.
– Genau. Deine Idee!
Ich bin nicht überzeugt!
– Jungs, ich brauche eure Hilfe!
– Inge, was ist denn los?
– Ach, ich habe ein großes Problem.
– Ja, jetzt setz dich erst mal hin ...
– Ach. Ich bin mit Jacques verabredet.
– Oh …
– Das ist nicht lustig! Ich habe ihn zu
mir nach Hause eingeladen.
– Ja und?
– Ich habe gesagt, ich koche.
– Oh …
– Jacques weiß nicht,
wie schlecht ich koche.
Er ist Restaurantbesitzer.
Sicher will er mich nach dem Essen
nie wiedersehen.
– Ach, Inge. So blöd ist er nicht.
Außerdem musst du das Essen
nur warm machen. Wir bereiten alles vor.
– Roulade mit Rotkraut und Klößen?
– Ihr seid zwei Schätze!